this will add hung in last Salaam
alaikum peace be with you this is a
greeting of Jesus Moses Abraham and the
last and final messenger sent to man
kind of problem Hamid peace be upon him
a message
yes messengers were sent and they came
with the truth and proved to provide for
the people because somebody can claim
that he speak in the scripture
revelation from God what proof did they
bring to back it up and Islam gives all
the proof that this is indeed the truth
from the crater that happens in earth
and that's what we're gonna be covering
today the scientific miracles you ask a
person says you know what do you believe
in God and do you you know what are you
religious no no I'm into science
well Aslam doesn't conflict with science
this slob paves the way for science what
yes and that's what you're going to have
to sit tight for to hear all the proofs
and truths that Islam provides so you
can know indeed that this is indeed from
the one creator that happens in the
earth sit tight don't go nowhere
back here on the Dean show with Sheikh
Allah some on liquify eCos laughter look
at this please be with you peace be with
you to a child time is short so we're
gonna get right into the topic God
Almighty he created this whole universe
and everything in it and the people who
are watching now they got away from the
baseball the football and all these
other entertainment that are out there
and they want to see what Islam has to
offer and I opened up the show and I
said science we know that Jesus he came
with certain miracles to prove that he
was a messenger so did Moses and all the
other messengers but today we have a
living miracle the Quran which is the
verbatim Word of God
so we want to go into some of the
scientific facts we know that some other
religions they conflicted with science
and he used to kill and persecute the
scientists because now they were show
contradictions in their books but it's
amazing that Islam leads the way to
science and there are certain facts in
the Quran so we're going to talk about
these and how could we know that indeed
after listening to you or we will know
that how can this come from anyone else
is it possible it's actually impossible
for anyone else other than God Almighty
the one and only God to come up with
these things because the next time
possible or impossible for anyone almost
1500 years ago to come up with all these
scientific facts that no one else knew
except with the last hundred years some
of them see even in the last twenty
years or so so the beauty of Islam and
the beauty of the Quran is actually
challenges you doesn't just tell you to
believe and don't ask questions as a
matter of fact God Almighty knows
a father yet the Brunel Koran will they
not ponder reflects upon the signs
wealthy and fussy come a fella to pursue
our own in thy selves will he not ponder
in reflects meaning the miracle of your
own creation and look at the to see
hopeful Rome on the earth and look at
the miracles look at the signs so God
Almighty is actually challenging you he
is telling you go go check ponder
cross-reference don't just submit do
this yes we were told to submit on
certain things that we cannot comprehend
we understand that part but since we're
talking about the scientific miracles of
the Quran we're talking your language
now now you're saying it's a this time
in age you tell me that you know prove
it to me because I don't believe in this
I don't believe in that you know I'm not
this religious type of guy and this time
that I said okay if you want to leave a
religion aside obviously we don't
recommend it but if that's the language
that you speak we'll speak your language
what language do you speak proof will
give you proof and as a matter of fact
that Almighty says this those they're
not equal ladina alamou now maladies an
errand they're not equal those who know
and those who don't know so acquiring
knowledge so now if you know that Allah
subhana WA Ta'ala is gonna give you that
challenge the onus is on you you have to
check now the ball is in your court
because God Almighty says in nalada okay
you're welcome and I tell you hey
remember for seam allowance you unless
you want to change men themselves so be
honest with yourself at least give
yourself a chance this chance is right
there in your on your fingertips when
god almighty tells you here's the proves
that with an oligo magnet fill a sock we
will show you our signs on the horizon
till do you know that this is the truth
that comes from thy Lord and no one else
speak with that affirmative and that
conviction except God Almighty so I
actually when I have some of the schools
coming to our Center talking about
comparative religion also want to learn
about Islam I tell them the same thing
which I will share with you now if you
don't got permitting that the the time
is available now the the question I
posed to them my says listen do you
think Prophet Muhammad may peace be upon
him had an f-16 the what are you talking
about exactly okay very good so how do
you know what happens to you when you
ascend to
heaven how do you know how did he know
what happens to you when you actually
elevate and even you know when you hear
these things in the plane so highly
unlikely the pressure cabin changes you
will see this mask how do you know that
even in this order that's there in the
Koran says yes you can hard yeah
and now your sarcasm are as if you're
going up as if the pressure is against
your your rib cage and this is mentioned
in the for just mentioning the crab so
when you're when you're going ascending
high up into a different altitude in the
sky what's the same the pressure
yah-hoo like ontological yourself is
somehow your pressure that your rib cage
will actually concave will be pressured
as if you're ascending in the Indy
heavens who knew that who no one
actually got up on the Indy heaven Saudi
but you did you just say he did here an
f-16 no he doesn't have enough sixteen
unfortunately but I'm pretty sure
everybody else may think that way okay
now what I said okay if we proven that
he did not have an f-16 do you think he
had a submarine bohot now you ever have
16 so now or submarine yeah so they say
I'm they shake their head and I'm pretty
sure he didn't have a submarine II
didn't he wasn't like a Jacque Cousteau
walking around with the
Bonet on the rift hand side or the cool
you know trying to look like a French
artist to say ho ho ho yeah no he was he
did not have a submarine so how did how
did he know what happens in the darkness
of the layers of the depth of the ocean
now the Quran is talking about salutely
this in the crown yes I mean I'm gonna
give them some challenges I want to do
some homework I will give you some of
the signs and I will challenge you to go
on find out yourself punch in you can
use shift Google you can use the
function very scientific world cause in
the Quran it will light up like the
fourth of July we will talk about some
of them but I will ask you I will
challenge you to go back and use the
internet to find out everything about it
it's impossible for us to comprehend and
talk about all the miracles the
scientific miracles in the Quran in a
very short time so we're looking for
just this simple path and simple journey
if you didn't have a f-16 and I'm pretty
sure he didn't have a submarine knowing
what happens so maybe he had a GPS
possibly a satellite huh no you're right
he didn't because how did you know what
happens then beneath the earth and the
mountains have anchors
that these were the altered this is the
anchors and they how they keep their
balance and the checks of the gravity
and so on all these things that are
explained in details nobody knew that
nobody actually penetrated the earth in
order for them to see that the actual
mountain is just the top and beneath
that is like an anchor is more than that
you need and need depth of the ocean
since he didn't have an f-16 or a
submarine or a GPS or any softly maybe
he had a Voyager yeah he didn't I'm
pretty sure he didn't so how did he know
what happens when he actually is sending
open any hemisphere there is seven
layers of hemisphere who knew who knew
then even though that we celebrate and
we do the success of the mankind now
going to the moon and all that fifteen
hundred years ago who would have known
that who would have known the theory of
the Big Bang who would have known that
even known prophet muhammad sallallaahu
you seldom that maybe he was walking he
has stethoscope maybe do you think he
did he had an ultrasound machine nothing
of the sort
I'm pretty sure he didn't want behind
stuff for a lot of hasha well I don't
mean to say anything that is wrong but
just to give you something that you can
relate to a language that you can speak
yeah he didn't have a stethoscope and
walking you know to check how the human
being was created pregnant woman in
Medina say well I I just I need to know
how the human being was created I need
to listen to it or put an ultrasound
machine see how the stages who would
have known how the human being was
created a step-by-step in great details
except the creator allah subhana wa jal
FeO that is the only one that knew how
the human being was created not only how
he was created how the steps of the
gender not just the the the the how it
was created they'll tell you that gender
and where he come it came from the
sources not just the people to think oh
because you're this type of a man you
will have this girl's only we used to
stop a man you will have boys only and
that's not the case
the government says Nina sold Ewok para
it comes from that male and the female
so now we know now in that in the recent
scientific in not only you will find how
it's created you also comes from where
not just the father not just a mother it
comes from the father and the mother
accordingly and of course some specific
parts of the human being
even up to the fingertips and the
fingertips Cordina and so we a banana
this banana the fingertips the
fingertips is a miracle in itself
how many millions of billions of human
beings were created amazingly enough not
everyone have the same fingertips and
God Almighty mention that as they can
and authors as well yes we are capable
of doing this why would it change why
would he mention this they say that's a
miracle in itself that are using it
about the DNA all these things are there
amazingly enough in a very short form to
talk about what God Almighty is giving
you in a summary what the scientific
milk is required in a nutshell what we
have to share these are these are just a
few and you left off the finger the
actual human fingerprint that we just
discovered that this separates every
human being there's no two alike that's
mentioned in the verbatim word of God
the Quran
absolutely Belair father Dina Allah and
the Soviet banana may we are capable of
that doing that that the banana that
fingertips and that the scholar says is
a miracle in itself to be mentioned over
almost 1500 years ago that god almighty
has mentioned that to attract attention
that you need not ponder reflect mafia
FOC come off a lot of saloon will you
not even look at your own creation in
that essence we're gonna take a break
and we'll be back with more scientific
facts not fiction that's in the verbatim
word of God the Quran when we come back
here and initial sit tight I don't say
the people I used to be a Christian I
still carry the values and principles of
loving Jesus Christ and perhaps even
more than even so I think I got the best
out of Christianity by becoming Muslim
so many other things that you can enjoy
without drinking a sip of alcohol this
is the same thing it's not an obstacle
it's not something to cause people to
get completely disparate and start
stopping living their lives no it should
be a motivation it's only one life that
you're going to be living so you better
do it for the last channel Matata
Mohammed could not have known these
facts about human development in the
seventh century because most of them
were not discovered until the 20th
century that God transmitted through
Mohammed bits of his knowledge that we
have only discovered for ourselves in
recent times 1,400 years ago when the
world was immersed in darkness the Quran
was revealed which brought light to a
beleaguered world and whereas the
earlier books came with many scientific
mistakes due to the hand of man having
delved into them the Quran had none of
these contradictions the world thought
there could be no reconciliation between
religion and science but the Quran
mentioned many scientific facts in great
detail like how a human being developed
in the mother's womb and described other
scientific facts which amazed the
world's renowned scientists and
scientific community back here on the
Dean show and we're talking about facts
not fiction and this is one of the
things that I I read a book and people
get this book free at the Dean show calm
it's a brief Illustrated guide to
understanding Islam I had listened to
the purpose of life by Khalid Eocene
it's also something I recommend and I
was I was investigating checking up this
checker I wanted to before I submitted
fully in Islam will make sure that what
about all these other religions how
could I know that these you know they're
claiming they're from God I want to make
sure 100%
and what really lifted up my conviction
were these scientific facts I read one
and then I had in the book what the
experts in this field are saying that
there's no way that this could have come
from a human being so you mentioned a
few and somebody I would say all this
coincidence all
guy he was brilliant oh he was a
superstar you know but now that we keep
going and going
it just can't it's impossible so give us
some more of these you covered the
fingerprint you covered the depths of
the ocean and you cover it all so when
you ascend God is talking about what
happens
so you give us some more talk to us some
more about some of the other miracles in
the Quran not only the miracles of the
Quran that actually is proof to anyone
even scientists become Muslim because of
that and we know some of them of course
is Maurice pookkalam and so on they've
written books about this specifically
the creation of the human being and
everyone knows that when God Almighty
told us that the word Alec that the word
that's something that hangs when I go
into details into this how it started
from Mokpo a drop of a sperm and how
would then it became a mudra you know
that there's something that hangs in the
womb then it became that root sustenance
and God Almighty goes into the details
and after this is that iran-pakistan
ramanamma
then it goes into that the vertebrae
then you cover it with a with a flesh
and it grows and amazingly enough not
just in the Quran when prophet muhammad
may be upon him says that even the
angels will come and blow in after 120
days then you look into it ago amazingly
enough that's when it starts life it
starts when things are decreed decreed
them in the written for it
so not just any human being these are
the scientists and specifically
scientists if they become a Muslim
that's a major proof that they are the
one that they actually defy anything
else except the proof
don't tell me about religion don't tell
me about anything else so when
scientists themselves discover these
things it is a major proof that the
Quran is actually the Word of God there
are certain things of course that god
almighty says some Achrafieh that the
earth is actually been decreased from
that it's circumference how is it
possible for anyone to have been other
than the creator would have known how
the earth is actually being how it's
being treated expanding or decreased
except that god almighty speaking of the
earth in a sub one it means the ocean if
you look at the the rocks itself how it
actually react to it who else would have
known that the fresh water does not
actually
with the salt water amazingly enough
love soup an hour to add again Superman
they know about the whole area Brianne
between him there's a veil that they
don't actually mix salt water with the
fresh water nobody took a lab or a boat
inside and found out even where the
fresh water was or that the salt water
was no one knew where the river came in
and met with with the ocean water and
took a sample from here a sample from
here and no doubt there's a density
different density different contents
even amazingly enough the ocean life all
the marine life and everything else it's
not how they have their own characters
is how they don't mix how they live and
how they actually seen the birth of that
Vale that actually protects them form
and smooth it's amazingly it's in the
Quran absolutely it's in sort of a rapid
of course by now mother the whole area
margin Bahraini altitude the mainly to
seize the freshener yeah but by the
Houma between them there is a veil that
they do not transgress for one another
this one here stays as their content
that one here stays in the content and
if anyone tries to do that at any lab
you add this in yet that they will be
mixed it's impossible only God Almighty
knew that secret and only God Almighty
kept the characteristics of that not to
mention that even water itself
we know it's h2o the contact itself yes
if you do if you put hydrogen and oxygen
in the lab together what happens it
explodes I'm not asking you do this do
you have a lawyer here and we have to
put a disclaimer on this one please do
not try this at home
but look at the capability of God
Almighty the context of it is actually
should be blown up but God Almighty
takes the way that characteristics of
that for us to be able to live among it
and get the you know the fishing and the
livelihood and the pros on all that we
use it at most transportation and so on
but imagine imagine that the capability
of the Creator telling us ominous and
the cycle of the the evaporation the
water the cycle who goes to the clouds
that comes back to the rain and what
kind of clouds gonna many actually
mention this at the con these are the
heavy ones that are now telling you that
we
you know we know which one which one is
reigns God Almighty told us that over
almost 1,500 years ago told us which one
that carries which one of the cuz it
doesn't carry water and the wind and the
cycle and so on well and is Ellen that
happy there's another miracle himself
when god almighty says the hadith the
steel has been descended meaning the
contents of the high didn't solve it and
that we have the done here it's too
grave the scholar says forward to me is
this the iron the iron that comes that
God sent down that is correct
yeah because of the the scholar says if
you look at the the breakdown or the for
the for the actual metal of steel it is
impossible for us to have been formed
here so economy what ends Elma we have
descended the the steel theha best of
courses who was also mentioned what it
was and so on in the essence looking at
the bigger picture about the big the big
bang theory that is the map well general
traffic on Akuma they were one layer and
they were actually taken apart and there
are so many other miracles of the Quran
when it comes to the scientific facts
again I'm going to challenge you one
more time to go back and google it
scientific miracles in the Quran and you
will see it again
too many for us to talk the milk in the
cow can you elaborate on this one
subhanAllah that is another miracle says
Allah upon our to a lion stockless Allah
imagine the the milk comes between forth
with them meaning you know zelda come
love you god bless you don't miss
anything that is not befitting
accordingly but it is that what we have
in the stomach if he sees the faeces
yeah and also the blood you would have
thought that a milk that comes be from
between the faeces and and the blood
would come with a certain smell at least
a certain aroma reasoning because of
what it is or even that comes with a
hint of red here because of the blood
but amazingly enough gonna mace is
there's another challenge for you it
comes from the stomach where the the
faeces are there and the blood is there
but it comes with no smell and no traces
of red of the color but it comes pure
odorless and pure
white milk this is in the Koran in the
Koran honey
are healing from Allah the honey in
itself that be if you look at the B in
the documentary about the bees and so on
you'll find out that it's a miracle by
itself how the creation of the bee and
that's why they were actually mentioned
in the Quran and they have a whole
chapter in the honor of the bee of how
God Almighty says that he will actually
go on under the flowers and the trees
and they were the extract and they come
in and what finish if I did say in it
there is a cure not the right otherwise
every illness that we have we could have
simply taken honey and that would have
been healed but that's not the case is
fahisha fat in probably amongst it from
that we can be certainly used for cure
and you'll know now that the the the
Jill that they saw the honey bee and and
so on that they actually use now
especially when it comes from the Queen
is very expensive why they use it for
health purposes the pure illnesses the
the naturopath and all that stuff is
used for that simple fact
who knew that then over 1500 years ago
that or it were almost 1500 years ago
how this came and what it comes and what
importance of the honey itself except
the creator of the bee which is God
Almighty one more one more before we go
to break that we're all created from
water so parent la imagen the context of
the human being how many and you take it
you find out actually it's the context
of the of the earth but the majority of
the human being is actually water and
what you have let me know equally che in
high everything that has a life for
sustenance it is from water the source
of it even though the Prophet Muhammad
may peace be upon him use that line when
he was migrating when he was asked where
are you from he says from minimap from
water so again either the mat in Mahim
some of the scholars created majority of
water occurred the liquid or mat meaning
that the the sperm that we were actually
created from both accepted and again
this is again the miracle of God
Almighty only the only the one creator
that would know where we were cheated
from amazing amazing
be right back with more here on a diesel
sit tight no problem you can take my
daughter to dinner you and my daughter
and me have a good time you should have
a good time
otherwise though Islam is the fastest
growing religion in the world and most
of the converts are women not men they
see that the rules of Islam
instead of constraining it the rule
second
back here on a Dean show and we're
giving you the scientific proofs there
are certain prophecies historical facts
all these things we're not covering into
this show we're talking about the
scientific facts this is not fiction and
you name you went over so many tell us
not in what context is the creator of
the heavens bringing these verses is he
talking to the human being and saying
consider this if it was from this how
would you know this and that give us
some of the examples of the context when
God Almighty talks about these these
facts of science that he's talking about
certainly is speaking of the creator's
language is it speaking of challenging
as a matter of fact that Almighty gives
you two challenges and that's why the
scholars actually say if anyone has the
audacity to prove something it is a
fallacy or or not they have to have a
question in order for you to say that
there's correct or not correct god
almighty actually gives you challenges
not just a scientific fact of course it
tells you if you do this if you're able
to do this then this Quran is not from
God and he actually does the exact
opposite he says you will never be able
to do this sense you will never be able
to do this believe that this is from the
creator and word yourself from the
Hellfire and so on so only God Almighty
and only the Quran that gives you that
challenge I'm the same thing that God
Almighty gives you the challenge to
ponder and reflect and look at yourself
even though everything the poulsen
everything that your your we mentioned
about the challenges that God Almighty
has given us from the scientific
miracles on the Quran that speaks in
this language and speaks at this time
only the Creator would be able to give
us these challenges with the firm answer
and he's telling you since you will not
be able to do this believe in it and
since you will won't be able to do as
such in both of them God Almighty's
telling you believe so you made ward off
you saw from protect yourself from
Hellfire and so on a couple more points
before we come to an end you have
certain people these people that
verified these scientific facts are
experts in this field God Almighty in
the Quran says you know if you don't
know go to the people who know people of
knowledge and you'll see people let's
say they have a a PhD or a doctorate in
math or a person's a doctor just
a you know regular practitioner and
medicine and some people they have an
agenda they want to try to disapprove
Islam but because they have this doctor
in front their name they'll say no this
is false okay
have you come across this and then
they'll post some articles which the
experts who are doctors or scientists
and they just studied embryology for
example for their whole life they'll say
this is fact but if someone has a
Matty's a mathematician and then he's a
you know saying this is not you how do
you deal with this amazing I think when
the Lau Savano Tallis's was a little
addicted quantum let Salamone ask the
people of knowledge if you know not and
we mentioned before in another episode
it says if you actually have a car in
problems you take it to a mechanic if
you want to have you know if you have an
issue with your plumbing you will not
you would not go to a doctor
so in this essence we say specialization
specialization is the key word yeah so
we certainly if we talk about embryology
we go to a doctor that has studied
embryology and that's what God Almighty
actually gears us and challenge this
this discussion toward so we go to the
special special in that field and ask
him accordingly we give him the
credentials and we give him the the
benefit of the doubt accordingly because
we go to a doctor
he's just take one pill here one throw
there you don't say why and give me the
proof and on so on because we take it
for such that he's done his lid devoted
his life to study that and when God
Almighty says go to these people to
prove otherwise and they say they
confirm what God Almighty says in the
Quran we have to submit from the Creator
and they created that they are on the
same path and the same answer one
specializes in this field so not anybody
who just say a doctor and he's just
blowing how they are writes an article
you know go to the specialist who's in
this specific area absolutely and just
tell us in the last minute we have
advice for those true seekers that now
they come to the Deen show and they like
what we had to say and you know what
they're like you know what this makes
sense what I'm on is not making sense as
confusion and I'm not getting that peace
talk to these people please first and
foremost to open your heart don't come
into Islam with a preconceived idea go
in with an open mind that if you find
the truth follow it use your own common
sense don't listen to every time they
can hear you and don't go in whether the
hype or the misconceptions of what you
heard
be a smart individual intellectual that
you make your own decision accordingly
so God Almighty in the Koran says well
Edina Jaya had to afina an lndian know
him so good enough those who strive in
our path we will guide them to our ways
but you have to have a clear intention
and sincere means in order for you to
want to find the truth and if you're
sincere about it
God Almighty promises he will actually
find the truth for you and help you to
do it because the guidance is two types
the type and the guidance that he will
show you the way and the guys that will
aid you to be able to do it and that is
totally up to you because if you want to
change God Almighty will change you I
ask God Almighty to show you that what
is right is right and follow it and that
what is wrong is wrong and stay away
from it and make us among those who the
speech and follow the best of it thank
you for listening thank you so much may
the Creator that happens earth Allah
reward you for being with us thank you
[ __ ] leasure
thank you for having me and thank you
thank you so much for coming to the Deen
show we hope that you come back we
provided crews evidences that will
hopefully stimulate your mind that you
will leave knowing that this is from no
other but the one who created you
designed in the case of designer and
there's one designer who create designed
this whole universe and everything in it
and he is the one that jesus peace be
upon him Jesus didn't pray like this or
this as is recorded in the gospel
Matthew he fell on his face and prayed
to the one God and that's what we're
asking you to do to cut out all the
intermediaries don't pray to a man or a
woman or the Sun or the moon but pray
for guidance from the one who created
you the one God the creator of all that
exists and from there the guidance will
come from there the truth will come and
the truth will set you free
and that's what we all want to be upon
the truth and that's how we can truly
have peace within ourselves because but
first we got to have peace with the one
who created us so ask for the guidance
ask for the guidance and the guidance
will come but ask for from the one who
created you and we'll see you next time
until that peace be unto you in every
individual there comes a day when they
need to take a second just to
contemplate about
man I wonder why am i living it
justified I'm breathing my days
decreasing God please hear me yeah give
me the reason why you bought me in this
life the truth I wanting on jobs and get
so depressed I'm stressed no control of
my soul like a hole in my chest can't
sleep at nights so I drop it to the open
watch the stores while I listen to the
ocean